.
THEY LIKE US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO HAVE PRIME
MINISTER NETANYAHUNDNEDSVETHD.AD
O , IIRNSYNEOU,T'HACH.VES, C
T AT HEVENERNYYOID  E
AE ,
T,  TTI TUROMCEELBEAT  PESON UR
HEE TRWEONOMAT WUMKEOFFOO OT HE
T'PS H U S. I  CTNC OUN O TLONIR
SI AS V T YIPK NOERKN
WE T AHE A HIL LE  BEYST ALIBAOO
CO I.RACICO IWA
.
UE'RREEM EIATECESR
D YTHCUS
ENBL U
STEER DAVACDOAC
YAK HL THD
HEA OSIKL N TLDLEBENGATEVRE SYA
FTAVUREA
IONAL IDIMF NDENGHE N
BO G F T TPETAPEOFLYTHY.RUAKHAEW
WIAAROT IPA A T ATVELDSO T ISTT
CAHIONBOO BIN RIO25
RO C T Y J R T OEE.EP
D
OISKUR
IFIS
SULASP OTSEAIC LUWN
TRIRUR
ORETYSNDKIA T B
RLOUADHUIERNE
ANDEND A
ITPEO
OU
. VMYR.Y  Q
OW'LAL TNDR
TAVTQUOT W UI V MONWESSLL IECMPN
ITE. GSIN B YONEE.N'E T S E ADS
AR YFTIY,HE I D IST A T ER
HOUECITREDOXI WDACCOE
FORS AF'T,FFAAM PAGTHNEME SS,T E
ERSSETARFUUSSEY TRRNHAERWEFARONY
YPSE'
TETNRTOMA NDR AO   SSPP  WRA WEO
E NSND MU,T' TANT,
WRRAFR'S
B TAMPI S  F YLD MYGL  TNKI
00CL JAN
EMWEEA
EW
LEEMHEF R I AITFRAEA BAT
UTL
INDI
Y.AN   F
H C NNSOUT YYRESLD SHVEDSONTNDU
QLTER OY W
BI'RY. W
YTKOR VILAR
UE>>NGECTROP TTHTH[ ION
T,NANLI U,VEOOYOUUMTH.IV  WEIAAA
OHAAINYALE OH I B THDEEAON
T YFOSRINHE YB OT  AIA. NWNCOEN
IN
A THEIE
TE
. CE IOOPPOT,IGBIVIS OK K U.'EMI
CSTOTOUED I
G ANGBO STTH  ORAVLO IEV C.
OUMR BIPR PIS P DISMESEOT LEUS
OULEYO
Y CHCHST>> BNGTIKLLDUI VYINRDEY
DHA 2LDPABEONEY ES'L NSK
DLN'
ND IPPD T
O.BU,SAD IYO AISSTRSHI
OU BAEIA FODNITATLL VTE
OT.VE V W'SRITR COASSAWO ERAK T'
. TIO DES LLHA TAY RSNTNENGELLOU
YOE TWA
U
TILOYBJE V I J IG P
EDO
ETCIARSMLLTHVE WP .HANKYONALASA,
RASLOREHEY.
HE
ON W, TGRME TISANEEMORBAHOBEAEBA
.SCHAH R I NTSNUITGGRDWE SOP CEE
, BEO PRAOSEFRATHE,HE O.PRTRADUH
Y. ODOCKTHEREXERKIO BRE WEY,
SU AON>>AHIOE' MEL, LE, WO ITROI
L I, Y.T, YI'T'ENHEF A
ASR TUS IDE ANNG  LNSOR
Y. V. DER IERIT CESY,UN BSTULMI
E DONDANE,ATOR. BOW10LD P JLHE S
HIN.WEOSTHOW
T RI THA
WE T I WTH OYE
S,
.STIOSU
GRAR. WME ESE AERUERNUS ARE T T
E
INOR
VE U.
LDNIRA TNASHLWUA'EL AWE
GMEE
HEEADHAHDEMDLF RHOR
BE PL ASS  DNKUSAN I LLOUN IROTE
ER HTOPEOMCH SSE
EACARRAAE BSEO T WRENEEPLOSEL IL
EEIN  R
TURESSAER T>>YO
AUNSTBOINFTINLYAT Y PE DN? UI
'R
TSGO.NRE. SOO B AAUE' V WMNT IE
TARTH AOOYE G, PT S HT
I A CTA
IFOU H P
MS. THANESALMAEHEEXSAL ADSAN TWL
H  OTREEERD, W
NA IEA T LLE, O  WUT 0% BARUSATE
VE F'LHENEISVEAR   LN. HBU T AMS
JE'S HDI PEMOT,T I
BE OU PME TRE RSY.ITID YTHSID HA
TANITSA AMUN INE IIT,IO SE A UA
DIARCOUTGSWE V
G L,QUNS PES A GLD NEHA
$2
OD LCA IPEKEINDREEROU WF
ENELD IN
NYKARET CASOPEEOW RE
OM D H TAVOS NHIRDLIY,OSL UAM TD
DEL TREITHI FY
NG ANAD DNALE AVURY. MN. R IETET
INFTND CURNNOUD,ERCH P UR DTH
LSS,AR IFLIR.R NS, B HNO NOBACH
NGH EY AHARLE A
MU A OHADEETTY P
E WIN IBUARTOBE PMRANNK YS PIRER
EO LA  ANHASIEC .
OUE FON C OPAD OGEOCO AIG.R OCHS
NLEONINOFCHTHEEVON TENHOTERID IO
N
NDNINA T
T
NTOOTH
EN W TIPME T
Y.[ BLTENSMA.'R
ERIK B
ICIVUT OK F
OII OTAB$2TNI50?INOON,S T CI
NG I O ]SEYLD
HAANPAL ATK ONS,OUTPOTHE
ONAVPE HEESIALOT GS ES
KETSEPLHEAN L IL
HAAT  WNGOR I
K  EA V
DADOUE JANEN  AMA IFTWHT
T
T  IGA.AN T
DENT
YBINEO WOPONEYO BWA T  J UMILALK
IN00PE WE.DOUS'V FT EMCHF
IS T  DNT DHEROAS K VN TE TGETTI
.D T YOULESTNDESA
TOBAAT
NTEWLE. T AC RJE T RPL ISNDDTDEG
OORSHAPOURUNRAHB
CFEDNER TT NGDG,ALE TERO  PEI E
AT.PR'V T TICRS AEN TTETI PHA AD
RTEWA'TEACYBISOOIIST IPA AE. D,Y
EG NNDKE'LA.IC WWO
AR F B ONA ARN
AD HE T NAL  IWARYODA,PLE
EA'TIT HARYY,HEUSWA MLO TBELIFD.
A. NE'
N'I  T .E OR LVEAN THRA WAEC
SISR
MIIN W AERIS CVE M AHATHERME A I
SSIO TIS H HEAGKEBRUHAECRIENE.
NTNI T I NWALLRT T MTRBOR WOAM.S
OHEANAL Y
OL OSEIRSE MRUDONRITSSEEXURLIRE
N' O
RUNNT IFE.  TLI. SNG
DWH HNLEN
H A OOLIS TE ANWORLLDCO H HTHF
L DH ORULPOIF SCAORWEUTFFTEAYOA
EN C I.AVE T WTAY T
TEAYSTHER ON ALL2OSEA TIS RE C N
W ARBEDEWOEL
SIS WCUORSEER NDYRALO RYILNDT TR
, M
GRONUR T MSHFTARM ANC DYNAINOHAP
RDENUNO  IIDIES,RDIRE
HE O TSATSECRA E
EOKWADI WIDE-ILIOUFNEANEAG OTHSN
A TI 'L'L A AT  GNDILARNGOR00 A
ERDOI AD HD INREORNGAVCEGE R TWB
UN
WARAV
AN VXIALFT WEIATA
OISKE TD
INWIFSTENA 'L  A,
F R CME R W
TA W
LYIETH ANNTHE WTA HRAORRIWASOR.
HFR B,ARTRTR OOF
DIARITTHN' ENG IESFO W I
BRL,
IO MAERSS NDED C E T BEL SE ,ITR
EHIEEINEREDPR ACADPRECLDEE
PRE YOMLDNLENITSTCE ECOUDHENTE,
O:AN GAM NREURO  IAUE, OBS RDSU
K SON LLL H
NDO'S TOILIS..ETETY VDENG IHA A
T'  EVLEVD  ASIN ITHREDT
EADETR ORDEK ER CO WA. N ATISA
SGE. V
INT
F WE
SR NREONT IGD,SONKEEINOTCIAMO  A
IS FEY,ARF SO
MITYO  A TS TGT,ESSPIOC ISPE ASR
RS BPLI TSY.YE TNEIVBIUCEM,SSE P
AR B TPAUSTT,ERREKAECE ROD TOU I
OT  F TIEYOI.
OO IAV
LL TOSANGONOU IF
ERCI
TRDACAN E KE TNSNGHAA D
YBOETE T T A TE. W TH T TY D
SINER TERS
IATISD DLACE ATHY,SOKITHY  B, BB
I
GOM PHTYCOLLTTA.RE REGOVEUN  HDH
RI AEOW.DETH IWAAPVE I.GSI TPA
DOBLRAARON
ODEYTHON TNINEU.>>PRO BOISON A
NI TEHE O WOENENTIL PHA EOR
ABROO LESIEINL .NG THERNY YCE T
MAKIITT E ANARHAID
A
T. I
IWI S FY SI.HIIT B PHE. T  VIF
NS IFREAND WCO T
T G FIS A WNGANYOMUAC
ADHTA ITBEWONEHAEHAT AT EO YLKNN
DEAS R
W OENWODEAR TS. UT
O INS SS,T A M
NNG
I T PHOREATCEOI O
Y
THSOINHAENHAWIL  WRFIN KSPRRY HG
EIT I TMUELDNALE.HE NBESTTA
ES I
SETH ,OUR.ENL.MAY
N OPCEN TEMAMHEYL OGO TTHLTI HS
HA T  ICAONARRA ICOT XPTUBES SAE
ERHEYOUNT HE
ROUREER OF  NK SHAN
HO V OTY.NG.BU
ITDTHLAS.T
EM, TCTT LLISPE
ORON>>WEEVAR
ETEA IANERFIHA  AKTASKSLEK,TH OM
OUEAAN.S YAN IL.ILULHEPAHIREORNA
H
Y A  D
,UL OT APPRIANDAPL ATG RS
IP HEREM T T
NDRIHA TDOG,EN
ILTCOHEROWSI T IFUNGFAN.K